what's up everybody it's me greg miller
and that's the Prada Long Island calm
where we are to be here they went to a
good start ea's thermal am so impressive
let me tell you is a technological tour
de force at the beginning of the show
people were thinking in the comments Oh
kind of funny step their game up they're
not the same five guys who work in a
spare bedroom I have a tie on people
think your professional when you got
that but then we really quickly when
Cisco came out and the whiteboard was
here we we showed our true colors that
anything goes here we just don't care
yeah how are you though sir I am doing
just fine at 83 my 16 T your sixties
greeting t3 you don't look you don't
look a day over a 10 year when I was 12
is this could be the best III and I'm
just seeing a little logo right through
there oh so was battlefront look at that
and that feels to me like the game of
the show already I may be biased just a
little bit of ice yeah that bias so tell
me does this ever get old does III ever
get old hey you know the energy the
excitement the way our industry since I
joined to launch the Dreamcast if you
remember that yeah the little console
that could and couldn't yeah it is and
I've seen this industry grow more and
more people come every year and then
when you're looking around at the
screens just as I sit here and I
remember the days when this was all
standard definition you know a giant CRT
absolutely lots of pixels and screens
that really didn't show off the games
well and the energy the excitement of e3
it really shows how far our industry's
come and quite frankly how superior we
are to just about any other
entertainment medium hey immense is
source of pride for me having been a
part of this over the years I agree
hundred percent yeah so then here we are
on the show floor everything's happen
for EA how's it gone so far you had your
conference the show floor has been open
up we had a great conference yesterday
as we always do we led with mass effect
got a bit of a giant you Peter perfect I
got a lot of questions about this so
how's the n7 logo happening in another
galaxy was this human kicked over there
believe this is Whitney you're already
going downhill this is where mass effect
3 ended up you know you were going to
want to know the ending already
ah you know it's not gonna happen damn
it's almost had you trippy Lorena Minh
mirrors edge in the middle our sports
franchises look great palais means
nothing to you guys la being on the
stage was the thrill of a lifetime for
me greatest player that ever lived and
then being able to close the star wars
battlefront of me having the honor to
introduce leaner our executive producer
and stop yeah and the game looks
spectacular no that was the thing we
took away from when we sent our friend
Chloe to go see it at down at a Star
Wars Celebration and when she came back
and was telling so I was like I have to
see this game so to finally see the
footage yesterday and as you know right
through the 40 player live on our show
for it looks fabulous you're messing
around not we're not messing around
fully playable 40 player multiplayer
with the publisher as big as yours with
a vast library of games and studios and
partners how do you boil that down to 60
or 90 minutes for press conference how
do you figure out what you're going to
show and a variety of games are going to
show you have to touch on your sports
and your mobile and everything's how do
you do that so you said about 3-4 months
out and you have to work with the studio
is based on there's two things you have
to do the studio still need to deliver
the game right but to deliver the assets
as we call them the videos that you saw
yesterday usually you have to take a
team away from actually writing the code
and getting the game to where it needs
to be to focus on an e3 and then a
couple of months will be focused on
games coming Cologne and so you make a
value judgment of what we need to do to
either show you can do a you know a
trailer or your hack sure I have
multiplayer we made the decision that
battlefront has got to be playable on
the floor and the same with mirrors edge
so mirrors edge is playable right there
on the floor that takes a lot of work
from the game teams but you make hard
cause what you don't want to do is take
a team off to deliver an asset for a
show and then jeopardize the actual game
itself so you have to make those choices
as you go along how exciting was it to
finally get to reveal Mirror's Edge you
know I mean like last year yet III you
guys have to do they like it basically
we're working on it everybody chill out
but finally to answer fans right and
show all that footage well I I have the
good fortune have been able to go to
Stockholm on a regular basis and seeing
the team and seeing this game come along
and the one thing that's striking if it
wasn't evident from Cyrus presentation
is you've got a group of people there it
dies that just live and die for faith
the storyline
able to bringing this kind of
anti-establishment element of it and yet
it's a game that's based on stealth
you've got a very powerful female lead
which is important in our industry
nowadays and it's a beloved game was it
a massive commercial success not really
for us is it a game that game is wanted
and we felt obligated to bring back
absolutely and that's what we've done
yeah I'm curious to know more about that
because that's what I was thinking well
it wasn't obvious to go back to mirrors
edge or did you did you guys have to
figure out what does it financially
makes sense the people obviously want it
but it they may be there a smaller group
because EA has probably bigger sales
expectations than a normal but if it was
about making money you're right there's
probably other games Chiz there's
probably other just water right oh yeah
I get the good stuff Grayson get the
good stuff don't forget about the hot
peppers there are other games if you
just were focused on making more money
you could probably put your team on that
but the belief in the love of the
character the storyline from the
original game and our obligation to just
not leave it there a move on because we
probably couldn't make as much money
with mirrors edge it comes to it that's
wrong it's not players first for us so
team wanted to do it re greenlit it I'm
responsible for all the revenue in the
company billions of dollars it's my job
to go sell it and it's a very commercial
game now the interesting thing is you
know some people can't play it because
of the first person view and if you ever
tried the first one there was a group of
people the vertigo and jumping off the
buildings and that's even more enhance
this year with with the quality
obviously of the fidelity of the
graphics but I think this is going to be
a runaway success I don't lose any sleep
over my research I like it you gotta
weed them out yeah everybody's trying to
hold each other's hands it's Darwinism
you can't play this too bad get out of
here you had your chef me playing games
you can play first person get out there
go watch movies oops so you're talking
to player first initiative and I think
that shines through your conference you
came out your you basically are talking
about the tent poles that hold up this
conference and have all these awesome
things in it and then you go through and
you have things like EA ax
you have these different things you're
on mobile you're trying to engender new
games I is so an industry pundit right
think he is doing a great job at all
this stuff does it get you down when
like the haters in the comments who love
to hate on me as well want to come out
milieu who seduced well that's how you
get clicks used to lead off with EA
sucks right and then you go from 0 me we
were sorry trade as a company you know
for a few years it really started I love
the company i love the people that work
there and it was difficult okay worst
company america if you believe that not
many of us do but when that's the
headline if you lived in the bay area
and when that came out two years ago as
we do and CBS News led with that yeah
and your next door neighbor says you
work for the worst company in America
what's none of it we're not going to
stand in their backs yeah and so but to
be blunt we put a lot of initiatives in
place the idea players first is not a
tagline or a motto it's how we run our
meetings how we make decisions that the
number of meetings i'm in every single
day where some he said is that players
first let's think about that yeah you
know and we then reflect back and say
you're right let's do it differently so
the players with the belief that
ultimately if you are players first the
good things will happen sure you know
and that's the key to the whole thing
and i think more and more you're hearing
that in this industry as well you heard
it from microsoft listening bring in the
community get in the community involved
earlier in the development of the game
you heard it from sony last night sony's
love of the indie game movement is
evident it was last year as certain
leadership and things that were doing
unraveled look again if you want to talk
about that and that was the moment in
your conference in the game spot war
room where it went dead quiet in the
only person oh no like everyone was
riding with that little guy and yarny a
little guy and Martin's presentation
again is this a game that we're going to
make a lot no it's not yeah is this a
game that deserves to be brought to
gamers and wouldn't have been if EA
hadn't stepped in and picked up again
that it's developer and it's fun to had
dropped and Martin and that team of 14
developers had nowhere to go and Patrick
soderlund to his credit spotted him and
he
outer reaches of northern Sweden yeah
they're only he goes and these are the
giant walking said to us can we sell
this can we come eat could we even break
even ice yeah sure we can and you know
if we don't this game deserves to be
brought to market Martin you know that
the founder of the comic or would you
just such an endearing human being and
you know his story of Yanni and the fact
that that yet lon is love and the
further you get away from your love the
Lester's there yeah you have to bring it
all back in again I mean I've seen him
make that presentation three times i
tier up every single time and when you
meet him such a genuine care and that's
the thing right like we always kills me
we start having these conversations
about our games are a 12-1 you want to
fight that fight and I think we've
overwhelmingly won that it's art right
but it's when you meet the developers
the artists and you get to talk to them
and talk about how much they love it and
what they do and how they all work it
together that's the thing where it
really shines through in his
presentation right of his hands shaking
while he doesn't stuff like that he won
that entire room over cuz everyone was
right there with him yeah it wasn't in
front of hundreds of people he was
talking to you yeah I'm let me tell you
that was a risk that all of a sudden
we're going from boom need for speed
yeah Mirror's Edge boom FIFA and then
Martin walks out on stage just on his
own with his little yarn is clogged it
right and tells a story about love it's
a risk yeah of a sudden it feels
uncomfortable or even cheesy or
contrived none of that was the case and
he's such a genuine character bottom
line is it's our obligation because we
can afford to do it to bring that game
to market and it's going to be a lot of
fun you mentioned battlefront uh-uh up
front and obviously this is a game you
guys are super excited about for this
fall how big of a boon is just being
able to make Star Wars games for you
guys and is it is it you feel like it's
a big responsibility to treat it with
care since it seems to be that's a huge
responsibility and if you've seen some
of the videos over the last 12 months of
the team in Stockholm who feel honored
and privileged and as I led off with my
comments yesterday you know that there
are moments in your career and moments
in this industry that the defining
moments the people working on star wars
battlefront and Stockholm right now will
never forget ever forget working on this
game ever forget going to Skywalker
Ranch
never forget gonna muir woods and seeing
were n Dorothea never forget going to
Tatooine and half and they see it as a
privilege and our ability to bring it to
life with the Frostbite engine and some
of the most talented developers in the
world I mean when when we got this
license you can imagine every studio
that we had in the world said oh let us
have this yeah they were knocking out oh
yeah but dice got it and they sold into
it because of the love of the franchise
went when Lena yesterday of showing a
little girl you know i think it was with
a walker or eight I don't but yeah I got
that's how broad this this IP is you
know it's a 280 and it's almost with
trembling hands ourselves we hold this
license cuz we better hadn't screw this
up same way JJ Abrams met Adam screw up
the movie yeah neither of as well yeah I
think I'm sorry that seems to be the
case I everything we're gonna say the
same thing you see you bringing in your
most talented studios and assigning them
things that make sense for this is the
varsity squad yes one this is the 18 and
we owe that to Lucas and Disney we owe
that to George Lucas we owe it to the
fans we owe it to the legis this is some
of the most beloved IP in the world ever
Yeah right and all of a sudden it's
going to get the rebirth somebody is
talented as JJ Abrams on there and
bringing it and we're within three and a
half weeks of the movie you get to be a
part of that right usual to get into
this universe and bring in people like
Amy Hennig and have her sit down and
start graphics or ica me every day now
of course there's a whole bunch of news
about the story you want to recap it
which story would that be a me VA me
today Amy went out and she told us all
about the story but I'm like Greg it was
good maybe from Liverpool but I'm not
completely hahaha so one of the
questions I you know as a man who works
for this this you know it really runs
this huge publisher you get to choose
your partners and who you're gonna dance
with at e3 what kind of thought how does
that process go say well we're gonna
appear at Sony with this and we're going
to appear at Microsoft with this I mean
how do you kind of figure those kinds of
things well you work with your partners
we love them all equally we have
agreements with them that a
franchise-based they figure out what
what games are going to drive their
platforms
and then we kind of spread ourselves
around accordingly and and you know for
me it's always good to go back to xbox
because of my history my legacy and I
had a great morning yesterday you know
on the x x it's just like old times to
me saw 50 people still working the show
and the and the business that used to
work with me was fun same time fabulous
dinner with Sony execs last night and
talked about the business so we're a
third party publisher and that means all
of our platforms are important to us so
you balance it out I've done it for
years dance it out when i was at xbox we
would go after EA we aggressively went
after activision because we felt call of
duty was going to be a meaningful title
we aggressively went after ubisoft at
the time for Rainbow six and ghost recon
splinter cell but then this thing called
Assassin's Creed came along and then you
meet Jade Raymond you realize this is
all good yeah because it drives the
platform so and what xbox and
playstation execs look at what is going
to drive our platform where's our
install base going to come from because
software drives hard work and so
battlefront clearly is a type that's
going to drive hard way so for you
personally coming to 16 e3's what's your
reason to keep coming back what drives
you what is longevity in this industry
do you know it's funny and it's not the
answer you're going to expect is when I
walk from the south wall to the west
hall and the seven or eight people that
stop me and say can I have a photo with
your can I shake your hand or or you
suck because of Shenmue or whatever it
is just very what was that that's not
that it's that but but if the
genuineness of folks I love talking to
them and what are you playing right now
and and you know talk to a guy this
morning about crazy taxi and soul
calibur you guys were born but i
remember those hey my dream guess and
it's just me it means something to them
and for some reason I'm involved in that
you know whether they saw me at e3
previously you know for good and for bad
yeah and my legacy of Sega and then xbox
and now EA spans some interesting years
so I love coming here I just love being
stopped and being asked about do you
remember when or isn't this great what
we're doing right now so that's what I
really enjoy buddy three when when did
you notice this was more than just a job
like when did it dawn on you that when
you started all this that people gonna
be stopping you and I left reebok in
January I dad 17 years in athletic
footwear in sports market yeah and I
gotta call a recruiter said do you know
much about video games said well it's
you know saying I said I know Sega you
know why I know Sega cuz i bought a Sega
Saturn for four hundred ninety nine
dollars to my son and then like two
months later apparently there's no games
being made for her to get us what's that
all about yeah and but I got to learn a
lot about the industry i joined sager in
February of 1999 and by 99 99 we were
launching the Dreamcast yeah so I drank
from the firehose for an industry that I
got to learn quickly I got to love that
immersed itself in me as Mel's myself in
it and it is like an entertainment
medium that is different than everything
else I love music yeah we all love to
watch TV we all go to the movies but
these are passive and linear experiences
there for the most part of solitaire and
with the with the dreamcast being the
first online console and all of a sudden
it wasn't as on a couch playing together
it you didn't have to come to my house
anymore across the country across the
world yeah I'm bringing people together
like we do FIFA's a great example our
Battlefield franchise greg's I want
millions people every day friendships
are made marriages are born I mean just
the whole thing about connecting us
socially is a brilliant part of this
industry and I love that I've been
privileged to be a part of that journey
for 16 years yeah it's not chump change
column no no that's a long time oh it's
very long but I mean we're here at e3
obviously you know you're here
representing EA but what are you seeing
anything else from other publishers or
stakeholders that they're right up
publishers there are other believe it or
not believe it or not there are other
publishers Atlas is right over there go
dance on their floor there's good luck
with it you are they
yeah is there anything around that kind
of has caught your eye you know that you
might be interested in going on when
your eye is mass effect Mirror's Edge
FIFA star wars battlefront unraveled to
you we love you jaani wherever you are
where are you jaani I mean I don't know
why I don't have enough I mean I'm just
completely absorbed in our stuff down
okay I love seeing the annual franchises
the call of duty's it was great seeing
halo I lived and died I may or may not
have a part of my body that is dedicated
to their fort sir I was part of that
team dan Greenwald night we all work
together when I was a Microsoft so you
touch so many parts of this industry as
your career path goes through it all you
meet so many people and you know so I'm
always while since the competition I'm
always happy look when I was a xbox wii
new call of duty we knew college judy
was going to drive hardware sure we got
behind it we knew Assassin's Creed when
it first came up Gears of War cliffy B
Matt you had this this incredible yet
the Unreal Engine 3 you had this great
character in Marcus Fenix yeah gears of
war and it all came together around the
launch of the xbox 360 so these are the
things you can and you still have a soft
spot in your heart even though they're
theoretically the competition you know
do I worry that this holiday that halo
5s coming yeah you bet I do but but do I
wish them poorly no it's great for the
industry that great games come out sell
lots of hardware rising tide lifts all
boats we all benefit so now we've talked
about you at e3 you come out you know
now you're this giant celebrity this
massive celebrity every stopping you for
autographs message is the best yeah and
once it's gonna get my waist slider i
mean you drape this joke right of like
oh you don't know whatever else is doing
because you're so hung up on what you
guys are doing what is the average day
like for everyone knows you you come out
you make cool announcements everybody
applauds at you that's not a normal
monday for you write what i do every day
top down I I get to work and I think I
don't if you've ever been to our campus
in Rome I herro c episode you have a
lovely cafeteria it's a great rate
cafeteria I spent more time in the
fitness center
to be clear but I do not pay any more
time in the cafeteria great people we
have about 1600 people on that campus
the energy it's youthful and I probably
be like the second oldest guy on campus
which I'm perfectly fine with it's a
great place to work the creative native
the sims is there a battlefield hardline
franchise we've developed there I lived
10 minute commute from there get in
we're in a gorgeous location go for run
on the water and then I get to spend
seven eight nine ten hours with some of
the most fun people in the world and we
rally around each other and particularly
the dark times you were talking about
when quote-unquote with the worst
company in America we always had each
other we knew that just wasn't true yeah
and you rally around each other what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger and
we've emerged a better company a little
bit more reflective a little bit more
focused as we should have done on the
players the way we build our games the
way we market our games I'm responsible
for all the revenue and I'm held
accountable for that but at the same
time I also feel responsible for giving
players a great experience as best we
can and that's what EA is all about when
you started we started player first and
you started looking at games that
feature yarny characters you're talking
that you are the one in charge of the
revenue and all this stuff is it a
constant check and balance for you or
are you ready to take a loss here do
this to make sure that EA is making
awesome games you know what unravel is a
great example you look at it you do a
forecaster so that you get your teams
together and you say okay here's the
game here's that his history onra here's
the game here's the delivery date here's
the platform's here's the types of games
we've seen before what's the forecast
here's what it's going to cost to build
the game is we've got across the mark of
the game and you do a P&L and unraveled
might be one of those where can we break
even maybe but is it we are we obligated
to bring because we can because we're a
company that has built a decent balance
sheet because been success I think we
are yeah if not us who and this was a
studio that was about to die and to
Patrick Solon's credits spotted it we
have the resources to go help him bring
this game to fruition get it out the
door and if we sell a bunch great if we
don't and people who buy it have a lot
of fun with it that's great too I can go
sell other things
to make up the difference sure Madden's
gonna sell every year you're gonna be
okay FIFA we may sell a few copies of
battlefront it'll all be good they're
all going to be waiting for mass effects
which a guy advent humanoid character
with the n7 armor is in this other
galaxy because what did you did did you
pee your pants a little bit when then n7
thing lit up yet just you know just a
little maybe a lot just don't know when
that light came on there and there it is
and you suddenly realized what you were
seeing I was pretty stoked I'm very
happy with what you're doing you're
going forward it's excellent yeah I mean
I'm enjoying i'm actually a trava sheep
again i'm sure this already neogaf is a
flame with threads that's right that
we're real or imagined already yeah they
don't even know they think they know the
ending so that now one thing we haven't
touched on you showed up at Microsoft
first thing Monday morning talked about
EA access why is that an important
program for you guys I think the ability
for us to be able to give gamers for a
very reasonable amount of money the
ability to sample all of the great games
we do nobody has a bigger portfolio in
this industry than electronic guards
from the fever's of the maddens and the
NHL's and the ufc's to the need for
speeds to the unraveled to everything
that we do in our FPS in the first
person shooter category not just
battlefields but also titan falls plants
vs zombies garden warfare so you think
about the breadth of what we deliver as
a company it's difficult to have a
consumers spend sixty dollars whatever
they want to spend time and an
experience orbit so what do you do you
package it together you start building
subscription services and when we think
about our end our industry and
entertainment look I don't buy music
anymore I'm a spotify subscriber does
thank you I don't need to own I gave all
my eight tracks ok Bob because I never
moved on I've gave them all the way
because I am very confident to the day I
die that music will be in the cloud and
I can pull it down anytime I don't buy
movies anymore and I rarely go to the
movies because of netflix i pay 799 for
netflix great vibe for money if i need
to see a movie i'll do comcast on demand
and i pay 99 t nine at best nine dollars
and ninety-nine cents I've a being a
Spotify subscriber
I discover music in ways that I would
never pay for music and I've had fifty
dollars in my itunes account for like
two you ever Mugen can get rid of it I
don't want to buy music and so this idea
of discovery is it the roots of what aea
accesses look you got 12 games in the
vault right now more games coming so we
announced titanfall then down the road
dragon age inquisition I took to so many
gamers the guys that stopped me out here
say I'm an EA access subscriber I'm not
a soccer fan but fever was there and I
started playing it and it's like oh my
god this is so much fun nice and and
that's the key it's about discovering
you and I listen to music yep throwback
Thursdays or whatever we have fun the
playlist that all those were awesome you
something you wouldn't have bought it
notice about discovery you add ten
percent discount and you add five days
early early trial on the game but you
throw me of it you throw me off I love
you Peter they're kicking me off they
gotta kick you out it went but what I
went to tech I know I know but I could
talk to you for now it's a shame to
leave don't leave that ladies and
gentlemen he's not leaving a new kind of
funny memories leaving EA he's here for
kind of funny we're gonna go a word from
our sponsor a trailer